all right 617 830 4750 let's take our
next phone call from the 262 area code
call or what is your name and where are
you calling from I am exactly teaching i
am from background wisconsin great
what's on your mind today from Wisconsin
I would just like to talk about the the
tax return being that Rachel Maddow yeah
and how that affects the negative
effects I so what's your question um uh
does it does just really like does this
will change anything about Donald Trump
is like they can better than to make him
worse well it's a no knowing risk on the
ice Trump better or worse but what it
does is it probably if you're in the
camp of people who are concerned about
what Donald Trump's full tax returns
would reveal it basically does nothing
because the tax return was just the
first two pages of his 1040 and it tells
us nothing about the sources of income
it doesn't tell us anything about
business holdings it doesn't tell us
anything about lenders that have that
have loaned money to Donald Trump if you
are at rumpus of sorts you see this and
maybe you say hey look see there's
nothing to see here he paid twenty-five
percent effective tax rate that's higher
than what Obama paid in some years and I
think that this was as I said before I
got the sense immediately that this was
leaked by the Trump White House itself
and I don't think that anybody other
than Trump really did themselves any
favors with the reporting about these
two pages that that's my view and I've
been pretty clear about it yeah I was
just because when I saw it i'm like old
i first heard about like okay there's
gonna be a big story it's going to say a
lot but it doesn't really seem like this
they pay taxes makes I mean it just says
that gives it a fact is I mean they need
to release the rest of it this is sequin
years but whenever that comes out that
comes out yeah and it's not just about
releasing the subsequent years it's also
we need to pull tax return with all of
the schedules so I agree with you thank
you so much for the call really really
appreciate